President Felipe nooses seeking a second
term he voted when the polls opened
Mozambique's capital Maputo this party
who Nemo has been in power
ever since independence from Portugal
more than 40 years ago the country since
the time it decided to resolve its
destiny through electoral cycles has
never failed and also this year didn't
fail that meant millions voted at
thousands of polling stations across the
country
with the exception of cover delgado
province where the government's fighting
an armed group some polling stations
there didn't open in Maputo many queued
for hours this polling station hundreds
of people are lined up waiting to votes
Polly Moe was announced the winner in
this suburb in local elections held a
year ago but it took more than two weeks
for the result to be announced
opposition say that's because it was
rigged rights groups and opposition have
already complained about serious
irregularities in this election well
super mamadi leads the largest
opposition party caldron amo he voted in
the northern city of Nampula Minami was
once a rebel group and fought for lemo
in the 15-year Civil War they signed a
peace deal for the third time in August
his supporters say they found people
carrying ballot papers predict for
frelimo this is what provoked military
hostility in the past we would like to
urge Philemon to stop these activities
because we never had a sentimental
opposition and rights groups have also
raised concerns about 300,000 so-called
ghost voters in Gaza province and
violence during the campaigns including
the killing of an observer last week by
policemen
the leader of the smaller but growing
MDM opposition party the VESA mango
voted in the port city of Beira which
was devastated by a cyclone six months
ago he also complained of violence in
the campaigns I asked the Defense Forces
to protect citizens do not intimidate
counting the votes is expected to take
days any delays will breed mistrust
mozambique stability ultimately depends
on people here seeing the election as
credible
Malcolm Webb al-jazeera Maputo
Mozambique